- Once I started to generously serve,
my product got better as an entrepreneur.
How many of you have a people plan?
See, that's the greatest opportunity
and why my company exists.
Because the last time I met you
I don't think I was my authentic self.
I don't think I was Keith Ferrazzi.
To me, mentorship is a
very misunderstood idea.
Leadership is about earning
permission to influence
and the role doesn't give
you permission to influence.
How many times have you backed down
from what you knew you needed to do
because you were afraid to ask.
Most intimate critical relationships
lie to each other.
And they shouldn't.
Small doses of incremental positive
experiences change mindsets.
So you change the behavior
to change the mindset.
The key is we recognize
that inside of all of us,
I think is greatness.
I think extraordinary things and we need
other people to pull them out.
If you take nothing away from the time
that we're going to
together going forward,
if you do nothing else,
but just remember this.
- He's an American
author and found and CEO
of Ferrazzi Greenlight.
His first book Never Eat Alone
was published in 2005
and became a bestseller.
He's been described as a master networker.
He's Keith Ferrazzi and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
(swooshing)
- You know, in retrospect in my life
I spent way too much time early on
as an entrepreneur pushing selling
as opposed to generously serving
and once I started to generously serve,
my product got better as an entrepreneur.
So, even in that area of
professional currency,
people who believe that their job
is to sell stuff versus serve a community
actually don't do as well.
Now how many of you in this
room have a to do list?
Raise your hands.
Of course, you do, because productivity
is important, isn't it?
How many of you have a people plan?
See that's the greatest opportunity
and why my company exists.
Because if your relationships
are so crucially important to your success
in so many ways, why is
it that you have not asked
yourself a simple question every year?
Who are the 25 most important people
to my success and how do I deepen
those relationships
authentically and genuinely?
- It's an extraordinary
book, Who's Got Your Back.
You write about the
courage to be vulnerable.
I guess that's true, give me an example.
- I'll give you one
right now and I'll do it.
I'm sitting here sweating a little bit
because you don't see it, I feel it
because the last time I met you,
I don't think I was my authentic self.
I don't think I was Keith Ferrazzi.
I think I was some guy trying to impress.
I met you at a dinner, you
may not even remember it.
- Chicago.
- In Chicago.
We were being interviewed on stage
and I was so excited to meet you.
You know, obviously, the
platform that you have,
the potential that if we actually clicked
and, you know, I believe in this stuff
and I want to create a movement of people
connecting with other
people more authentically
and seriously and when I
get nervous, I get bigger
and sometimes I brag and I perform
and other people get quiet and turn in,
but I go out.
And I did that at dinner
and I just felt myself
going further and further away from you,
which somebody I admired
and wanted to get closer to.
To me, mentorship is a
very misunderstood idea.
Most people think of mentors of let's
find a guy like Louis
here who we look up to
and would like to aspire to be and please
allow me to learn everything at your feet.
That's kind of (bleep).
- Which doesn't work.
- Well, I don't know if it works or not.
The bottom line is you are a mentor.
The lunch that we had together,
you coming up to my house, what I learned
from your podcast from your
work teaches me something.
And I can't find, I need
to find a group of people
in my life constantly
that I'm learning from.
They're my mentors.
- Yeah.
- I don't try to rest too much weight
in any one individual.
Our job is to create a set a road map
of individuals in our lives
through whom we learn.
Right, and I just started,
I was chatting with you a second ago.
I started a new high tech mobile
enterprise software company.
I am so out of my element.
But, you know, I'm raising money.
I'm hiring individuals, I'm
coming up with strategy,
I'm building a sales
force, I'm doing a lot
of the stuff I know how
to do, a lot of stuff
I don't know how to do.
I am finding mentors left and right.
It's survival.
- You are, yeah.
- So mentorship is about
relational learning
and if you think about it that way,
then you don't have a mentor,
you have many mentors.
- Around your learning roadmap.
- Leadership is about earning
permission to influence
and the role doesn't give
you permission to influence.
Most people think that the role does.
It's so, you know (laughs)
I've had conversations
with names that you
would know who are CEOs
of large corporations, we laugh together
on how the world thinks
that all they have to do
is say what they want
and people will comply.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Nobody complies.
Nobody complies.
People will do what they want to do.
They might do enough not to get fired
or not to be, you know,
openly disrespectful,
but deep down inside, they
do what they want to do.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- And leadership has
to work their ass off,
vulnerably, intimately,
empathetically, generously.
You used the word generosity.
Generously to earn the right
to ask someone to change
and that's a full-time job.
If any of you lead people,
if you're not spending 30% of your time,
30% of your time making
each of your employees
30% better, right, you're
not doing your job as leader.
As opposed to most of your time being
in meetings and dictating (bleep).
That's a big shift.
I'm not just going to tell my employee
to do something today.
I've got to make them 30% better, crap.
That's a big investment.
A big investment.
Now I come in and say,
okay, now how do I do that.
Well, the first thing you got to do
is you got to learn permission to.
If I gain vulnerability,
empathy, sympathy, care,
now I'm working with gravity, right?
And so you got to open
up gravity for yourself
as leadership and then it become joyful.
Then you start experiencing happiness
because it's two people in a relationship
caring about each other
moving an objective forward,
celebrating victory.
Celebration becomes the
currency for momentum
and this is happiness, this is happiness.
Then you're getting in the groove and
you're in the fly wheel of mutual support
and giving a damn and
people around you that care.
I mean (bleep) that's happiness.
So he were were sitting
along the side of the road,
it's November, Christmas is coming up.
And along the side of
the road, a few yards
in front of like the
car is a pile of trash
and in that pile of
trash, there was a toy.
I don't know if you know
what a Big Wheel is,
like a three-wheel plastic
toy thing sticking out.
Dad sees it.
He's like wait.
I know what he's going to go do.
He's going to go get me that big wheel.
It's November.
We had been unemployed
for literally six months
at that time and back then
when you were unemployed
for six months, you lost
all of your pension.
When my pop died, we
didn't have a pension,
we didn't have any savings and we had
a $5,000 life insurance policy that wasn't
enough to bury him, right.
And, you know, we had to accept gifts
to be able to bury my pop.
So there we were and here I am afraid
that my friends from my snooty school
are going to see us picking up trash.
So I'm hiding in the back of the car.
What do you think it takes for a proud
55-year-old steelworker to walk up and
get a piece of trash with
his son still in the car,
visibly embarrassed, piece of trash
for his son's Christmas present
because that's all he could do.
You know what?
My dad didn't care.
My dad wanted to make
sure that he had something
for his family and that's what mattered.
And he always said the same thing to me,
Keith, don't ever be afraid to ask.
The worst anybody could ever say was no.
The first of two very important lessons
in this story to all of us.
How many times have you backed down
from what you knew you needed to do
because you were afraid to ask.
I really hope you send
this message to your kids
and grandkids because
there are so many times
that I didn't think I
deserved to be in that room,
so many times that I didn't
think that those rich people
would accept me, that
I just plowed through,
pushed through because
my dad would always,
his voice would always come up.
Don't ever be afraid to ask.
The worst anybody could ever say is no.
- The challenge that
is see with most people
is they don't have a support group,
no accountability group or a master mind
or whatever you want to call it.
So how does someone want first find that
and figure out who the right people are
that aren't going to suck
the energy from them,
but also are going to give
and take at the same time.
- It's trial and error.
- Yeah.
- When I wrote Who's Got Your Back,
there's a chapter in it that talks
about the long slow dinner.
I think by the time we're done here
in a short period of
time, I want everybody to
watching us to have a
relationship action plan.
So, as we're sitting here
scribble down your goals
and next to every goal,
start writing three to five
people's names critical
to achieving those goals.
- Interesting.
- That's the opportunity group.
Then I want you to ask
yourself who to achieve my goal
do I want to learn from.
Write those names down.
Then start imagining who are the people
that I could trust around four core,
there are four core characteristics
of the lifeline relationship and frankly,
all relationships, but the tightest ones
have to have four things.
Number one is intimacy to
the point of vulnerability.
Can you I tell you when
I'm really feeling weak,
can I tell you when I'm
up against the wall.
Intimacy to the point of vulnerability.
Second is generosity.
Do I really want to help you and do you
really want to help me.
Do we care enough to help, generosity.
Candor, will you tell me the truth.
Right?
Most intimate critical relationships
lie to each other and they shouldn't.
Candor and conflict avoidance is horrible.
- Why to lie to each other,
because they just don't want to make each
other feel bad?
- Plication, they think
that that's their role,
to make each other feel good.
Look at me, I think a lot of it is
the people don't realize
that relationships
need to be leaned on,
the relationships aren't scarce,
that there, a lot of people
are conflict avoidant
out of a psychological
fear of abandonment.
I mean, there's a lot
of insecurities and fear
that drive our relational behaviors
and I have to say that conflict avoidance
has to be one of the most
erosive, erosive elements
of organization and human society.
So, the fourth is accountability, right?
But candor and
accountability together make
a high performing relationship.
What I would do is I
would list three people
that you have a strong
enough relationship with now.
You and I have, frankly
you and I have a perfectly
reasonable and strong enough relationship.
I call it a level two relationship.
Maybe we're bordering on a three,
but certainly two to three and three
is a strong relationship.
If you want to go to a lifeline,
which is in my world a three plus,
what you're going to do
is you're going to go out
and have a long slow dinner.
You're going to take your armor off
and you're going to say, look,
here's what I want to do,
here's what I'm afraid of and here's how I
think I'm going to get
there, what do you think.
And see how the person responds.
Do they respond with candor?
Do they respond with intimacy?
Do they let their guards down?
Do they respond with accountability?
At the end of the dinner,
are they saying to you,
dude, let's talk next week because I think
you should do these two or three things
and I'm going to hold you
accountable for them damn it.
Now if after the dinner,
they don't call you
the following week, then maybe they're not
the right person to be
your lifeline, right?
I know that was a very circuitous way
to answer your question.
- [Interview] That's great.
- What do most people do wrong
when they approach
relationships and networks
in your experience?
- It's a mindset and it's a mindset
of what's in it for me, right?
That's the first thing.
It's a mindset of what's in it for me
and it stinks on their suit a mile away.
What's in it for me?
It needs to be a values based judgment
of how you're going to live your life
and you've got to, now by the way,
there's an AA slogan called
fake it till you make it.
So, you know, the point is that little
by little by little, you've got to be able
to recondition your brain
and that's one of the things about
human behavior change.
Human behavior change doesn't
happen through knowledge.
If it happened through knowledge,
then nobody on a diet would
eat a piece of cake, right?
I mean, the bottom line
is we need to experience
behavior change, small
doses of incremental
experiences, positive experiences,
not even negative experiences.
Small doses of incremental
positive experiences
change mindsets, so if
you change the behavior,
you change the mindset.
We unfortunately have addictions
and I use the word addiction and I follow
things like 12-step programs
and other mechanisms
to shift behavioral addictions
because everybody who's watching this
has an addiction.
There's not a single
person that isn't addicted
to feeling less than in
a room, procrastination.
You know, some behavioral
addiction that holds us back,
you know, being too
shy, being to insecure,
being too whatever, tempers.
All these things are nothing more than
addictive behaviors that we practice even
though they don't serve us well.
So little tiny doses of new behaviors,
pushing yourself incrementally will be
the way in which we
change those behaviors.
- Why do we need someone to have our back.
- You know these difficult times
in this economy, there are too many people
that are under living whose
dreams and aspirations
aren't being things, they're parking them
off to the side just in
case of having survival.
The key is we recognize
it inside of all of us.
I think it's greatness.
I think extraordinary things and we need
other people to pull them out.
I don't know if you ever heard the story
of Jean Nidetch, who
founded Weight Watchers.
- Sure, I don't know the story.
- What she realized was
she was just out there
dieting like the rest of them.
It wasn't about knowing
that she had to eat less
or exercise a little bit more,
but it was when she started doing it
with her girlfriends that they started
holding each other
accountable for the things
they wanted to do.
That's the point.
Story is as a friend of mine calls it,
an emotional transportation.
You know, somebody says, you know,
what are you really passionate about.
Oh, my kids.
Great.
You don't really care.
It's like you just checked a box.
Now get them to tell you their story.
Tell me about that.
Tell my why you're so
passionate about your children.
Tell me a story.
Tell me about their last birthday.
Tell me about the last holiday that
you experienced with them.
Tell me what they did in
the last couple of weeks
that made you proud or
scared or interested.
Tell me a story.
What you're doing and what I want
all of us to do in this world
and this will transform your life.
If you do nothing, you take nothing away
from the time that we're going to spend
together going forward.
If you do nothing else,
just remember this.
Your jobs in life are to walk
around the world, creating an environment
around yourself that invites people in
to want to have a better
relationship with you.
Your job in this world is
to walk around the world
creating an environment
that invites people in
to want to have a better
relationship with you.
God, I just look out on
this couple of thousand
people and i just realize
that if everyone of you
in this room were to begin to do that,
the impact and the
touch that it would have
on your worlds and our
society for that matter.
Our churches aren't as
full as they used to be.
Our community centers aren't as full as
they used to be.
People don't join clubs.
They go into gyms and they put iPods on
and they isolate themselves.
Where is our community?
Naturally as human animals,
and we're animals.
We are hard wired and designed
to work in community.
Back in the olden days,
they were called tribes.
And the way olden days when
it was like 70,000 years ago
and there were only 12
of those tribes in Africa
and those groups if they didn't connect
and come together, they wouldn't survive.
As a result, as humans we
are hardwired to our DNA,
to our core to connect, to serve,
to help each other be successful
because if we didn't
and we were thrown out
we'd be eaten by mountain
lions by ourselves.
So we got to connect and we long for it.
When you do connect,
that's your time that I say
you feel and exhale.
(exhaling)
And somebody actually makes you feel
like you belong.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because B2 asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of Keith's
top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments
and I'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)